who's ready to see a great chess game
tonight yeah all right
plain white is Doug Brown stat USCF 1100
our hero black is me Michael comer yay I
wonder who's gonna win all right first
things first we flipped the board all
right he starts out d4 the queen pawn up
- all right so the best way to counter
that is with d5 all right he plays that
you play that how hard is it all right
so Knight to f3 protects the pawn pretty
boring stuff so we attack the knight now
what should white play to get an
advantage here he should bring his
Knight to e4 and harass the bishop okay
but he fails to he plays III so III is a
weak move for two reasons one it pins
the night and two it blocks in this
[ __ ] up all right so no good okay so
when black plays ecigs he doesn't have
the same problems that white has white
blacks that guy in while mine is free to
jet around okay so now he plays g3 very
confusing like where do you want your
Bishop here or here you can't have them
both okay so so try not to push both
those pawns okay
one or the other all right all right so
black counters with c5 very logical
bish up the g2
Knight to c6 just pouring everything on
this d4 square alright castles so now I
want a castle so I want to bring out
some of my pieces alright so Knight to
f6 now he doesn't want me hanging around
with the pin so h3 all right should we
capture pin pieces no unless it's gonna
be some kind of big advantage never
captured pin pieces because it just
relieves all the pressure so forget that
so [ __ ] up the h5 I'm not afraid of g4
just because it would ruin his castle
even more alright so so now he's got
this bishop that's stuck like he could
have seen that coming a long time ago so
he plays b3 where's this [ __ ] I'm gonna
go I guess there but so now I need a
plan to try and keep this pawn here
permanently
to keep this [ __ ] up bad permanently
makes sense
alright so obviously take it can he take
back with the night no because it's a
pinned piece
it doesn't really want to go there
either and he can't take back with the
Queen because my knight takes it so he's
got to play pawn takes all right but now
his bishops kind of good again so that's
a good idea
but but it makes b3 look kind of silly
though alright so Bishop to d6 and you
decide hey you know I played b3 I might
as well put my bishop there and that can
make him a super stir over there but not
quite alright so now I get castle you
got to give us night out and I be 2d to
be 5
I just don't want to play c4 but guess
what he's like I'll play it anyway I
don't care I don't care about nothing
so I got two players on this and he's
got two so the math checks out so so now
I'm saying well I played b5 I'm taking
you okay so so he takes takes Poe takes
now who is undefended in the white camp
anybody anybody oh this guy's pretty
undefended shy harass them yeah all
right Brooke the b8 that's where the
work wants to go anyway on this long
open file that's where that's where the
Brooks go all right
so he decides hey I'll protect them all
right so you're Queens a nine-point
piece all right you think it likes just
babysitting the three-point piece is
that very fun is that how you want to
spend a Friday night just hanging around
guarding this bishop I don't think so
all right so now queen is now she's got
a job protecting the bishop
all right out of the pin so I don't like
that
so now I'm gonna try to distract the
Queen like please go away please please
just go so I can take the bishop for
free make sense all right but he's a
little bit smarter than that so he
decides okay I put my queen back here so
now it's still protecting the bishop so
it didn't really work out too well for
me all right so now we got a tactic all
right we could play some hope chest
who likes hope chess yeah if you can't
hear the crowd erupted it with laughter
yes hope chess that's the way I win most
of my games but I decide I'm gonna play
good today as well as I can okay and
this I not to play hope just hope Jess
would be I'll take you
Knight will take and then I get Bishop
here
working the brook and the night so if he
moves his work obviously I'll take
having say I'll take the bishop but he
takes rook takes I would have played
this to be quite honest with you but
then I saw at the end my hope just
doesn't really work out because he gets
the night but if that didn't happen I
probably would have gone into that
variation sad to say but there's another
way I don't even have to play Hope Chest
and I can hopefully win a pawn anybody
and I give you a hint it's very much
just like the same variation very good
very good
our famous player in attendance
everybody's heard of him Grandmaster Ken
West shot it out the right answer yes
all right yeah you just go straight for
it okay so now rooks attack pawns attack
so he's got to move the rook I'm sure
he's gonna pick the right spot for the
rook yep so now take with the bishop
Knight takes cuz whenever somebody takes
something you have to take it back okay
it's just it's natural all right so just
take it back whether it's good move or
bad and so now I got a passed pawn I'm
loving this okay and obviously the Queen
can't take this
or else bye-bye bishop all right rook
takes Bishop everybody got that all
right so what do we do what do we do
what do we do
it's not even our move so the bishop
goes to f1 alright makes sense not
really because this bishop was really
good on this long diagonal he had a lot
of attacking chances like he moves his
knight guess what my knight would be
under attack here makes sense so he
takes his bishop from the GU diagonal to
the bad diagonal cuz he he's a little
scared of this pawn okay little scared a
little scared
alright so instead of protecting this
pawn which I do like a lot cuz he's
passed he's good I decided to make a
threat greater or equal to that so so
what's greater equal to that pawn this
Bishop so Queen to b6 all right so now
my queen is operating like a 14-point
piece okay that's how much power you've
got behind them all right because he's
got that rook back em up that's the best
way to do it is the power on the pieces
they either attack the same square or
get behind them and just just make them
stronger than their then their maximum
capacity alright
so Queen to b6 so he decides to protect
it rook to be one makes sense alright
Bishop to b4 attacks the rook and also
threatens the move c3 so he decides I'm
not gonna move the rook he's making a
stand he's making a stand so if you were
gonna make a stand in this position what
would you play and I'm not moving the
rook he says any any guesses any guesses
any guesses
Bishop c3 thank you so and now who's in
a pen
I'll give you a hint it's my black
bishop okay so black bishop is in a pen
so now it's like oh that was a mistake
all right so I got to get out of the pen
so Queen to a5 and I'm also hitting this
square all right
the a pawn alright so he decides I'll
take you I obviously don't want to take
with the Queen so I take Knight takes b4
and if he takes I'm gonna just take his
pawn and we'll trade and all that good
stuff so he plays a3 all right so
there's only one move I should be
considering the only move that possibly
saves this pond and it's a fork the
Knights only trick so everybody assumes
I go here which I do so he takes I take
so now my point is only two away from
becoming a queen pretty exciting pretty
exciting I'm getting excited all right
so what do you think white plays to try
to stop me
first things first he's got a trade okay
he's just passed away all right he wants
to all right so now his Queen isn't
going to be bothered with protecting
that rook okay so now his Queens free to
do whatever she wants now okay so so
she's not pinned anymore she's not
guarding a bishop so she can become a
force now who thinks he's actually gonna
make it a force no no but but she's free
to become a force of humans too alright
so rook to d1 this is where you want the
rook right behind it on the queening
file okay that way there's gonna be no
shenanigans all right there's no way I'm
ever gonna be able to actually get it up
there okay so that's where you want the
rook right on the Queen
file in these end games or games like
this that's where you want it because
too many cool tricks can happen when
this rook is not actually on the
queening square okay so so that was good
of him to put it right behind there all
right so I do not want to be back rogue
checkmated I hate that more than
anything in the world
alright so now by playing h6 my rook is
free to do whatever he wants to do all
right
rook to b8 alright so but you say hey
you just lost your pawn okay and I did
but I have this really cool move I think
Queen to f5 a triple threat can you
believe it but little did I know he
doesn't have to lose any of this stuff
so this guy's protected right everybody
agree with that he's protected by the
rook in case you don't understand that
at home alright so all we have to do is
protect the rook and the pawn can
anybody do that simultaneously anybody
Queen to e3 does unfortunately Queen to
e3 only protects the rook clean up one
very good all right so now this is very
discouraging I just gave up my pass pond
for nothing because I could not see his
defense of Queen f1 alright so what do
you think I'm mad now I'm really really
mad
alright so what more do you think you
make when you're mad h5 close g5 we're
gonna go for it okay so King to g2
so so now I decide pin the night okay
all right so pin the night so it's like
okay I don't like to be pinned so it
plays king h2 all right so you might as
well follow through with your plan even
if it is boneheaded and play g4 all
right all right so the night goes to a
good square e five all right so now if
you look now this point is in not a pin
because this rook is really really
protected all right so what can we do
here just follow through with the plan
file through it the plan that's the
reason why I played g4 g5 to take here
how should he change back I don't think
it matters but does it matter what would
a black play if he talked back with the
Queen here what's a really cool thing to
thread Brooke to be one threatening
checkmate either with the rook or the
Queen it doesn't matter all right so all
right no need to give them that counter
play so he takes back with the king all
right all right
so rook to b3 and white really just
doesn't have to do anything
and this really infuriated me all right
because because you think why I just
throw in your Brooke come on either move
it are traded or something okay
but it just stands there okay because
the Queen is protecting it so very very
frustrating okay all right so think
about that when you're playing defense
okay even though they're threatening you
if they're throw-in you're with this
same piece value or our greater piece
value you can just hang tight just stay
tight you don't have to panic you don't
have to move you
have to trade you can just improve your
position by playing King H - okay all
right so so now I decide okay I'm gonna
pin you now Queen to b5
all right so Queen to d1 route to be won
but it doesn't have the same bite as it
did before right
and in fact now where should this Queen
go because obviously you want to move it
okay Queen to d2 okay so that's that
okay so you'll be hitting if the Queen
went to d2 you'll be hitting h6 and then
and then even if you took and I took
your like still game you can't even take
your Rilke yeah Queen to d2 let's see
what the what the computer ends up
saying
forget the computer for a minute alright
so the move that was played Queen at the
- might not actually be that bad it
might it might be good because by
playing queen of d2 I can't really even
offer a successful Queen trade with
Queen f3 now white is on the attack here
okay black has been a little attack the
majority of the game obviously is
attacked and get as good as he wanted it
to be so now you know so now he's on the
attack and sometimes you just have to
face the facts okay even though you
might have been winning the whole game
it's things change okay so so now then I
know that I'm on the defense now I got
no chance to checkmate them my Knights
are under attack things are going well
I'm gonna have to just offer the trade
begrudgingly but you just have to go for
it okay so now so now he's got to try if
he takes the knight obviously checkmate
by either the rook or the Queen so he's
got a trait Yeah right he could do his
defense where he just moves his King
around and lets me do all the trades
alright so this is an easy one should we
should we make our pawns of the four
pawn islands or should we keep keep
these guys as a as a unit yeah let's
keep them as a unit okay okay so so if
you're counting a home a pawn island are
pawns by themselves so each has one two
three one two three pawn islands okay so
so if you're playing as either side you
should be like huh I should be attacking
the guys that can't be protected by the
pawns because then they're big pieces
have to stay and guard them okay so much
easier to attack
pawns all by themselves on an island
then connected once makes sense all
right
so knowing this what do you think white
please yeah obviously attacks the
connected one right
who would all right rook to f3 so how
should I protect it so I'm just begging
for somebody's to say this what's the
worst moving all at chess f6 week in all
positions even this one it's a weak move
because then he can come in here and and
harass me some more okay so we'll get
the f6 in in every edition of the
beginner breakdown all right so never
play up six so if you can't play off six
you got to play f5 alright alright so
even in the endgame f6 still doesn't
work okay alright so he's the salary
well def feel I guess I moved my King
around some more
alright keen to g1 so he attacked a
connected pawn so I'll attack an
unconnected one on an island alright
let's see how easy that was alright so
now he's got a struggle how in the heck
am I gonna protect this guy if I wasn't
looking at the sheet I don't even know
all right so it's gonna be tough rook to
d3
yup so he's right back at it okay so my
opponent is lower rated than I am by a
lot by almost four or five hundred
points so I figure I can beat him in an
endgame alright
so now Knight to c3 because his pawns
are both over here so I should be able
to get one of these
hopefully Knight to c3 Knight to c5 all
right so he's attacking my porn sorry so
even though I could I could probably
counter attack with this fork right
attacking that and that all right but in
an endgame all right I only have four
ways to win right if you think about it
I have to promote this guy this guy this
guy or this guy if I don't do one of
those things I'm never gonna win the
game all right
so so especially when you're going for a
win and not a draw which you should be
whether you're playing white or black in
this position just try to keep the
material does that make sense because if
he gets this guy
oh right say say I do play here okay and
I'm like yeah I forked your pawns way to
go and he takes this my chances of
winning have diminished okay so it's
true I get this guy and now he's gonna
have to stop him
but if you see that's probably not so
difficult
here you can play there and there and
blockade my pawn and it's gonna be
really tough for me to ever win okay and
there's no reason for me to trade a
connected pawn for one on an island that
hopefully I should be able to get later
on in the game because it's gonna be
really tough for him to to guard this a
pawn forever okay so so knowing all that
what move did I make all at once
yeah hang up some no reason no reason
straight all right so all right a for it
blacks my you know blocks everything all
right a for so I need the King to the
center of the board King e7 King up
three King to d6 alright I'm coming in
King to e3 this is good and this is
getting pretty intense King to d5 King
to d3 alright so here's the moment of
truth
alright so luckily I've been playing it
pretty fast
and I still have probably about an hour
on my clock here
alright this probably the longest I ever
thought about a move of my life alright
I probably thought about 40 minutes on
this move because it's pretty big
because because if i play my knight over
here I'm never gonna win i play my
knight over here never gonna win alright
if i play my knight here okay so he
could basically uh force a draw here
everybody see and i do not want to draw
this guy okay so what move do you think
i analyzed for forty minutes
ninety-four okay all right so if I play
94 there's two variations I have to
analyze the completion here alright so
obviously he's gonna take because if he
plays here I'm just gonna take his
Knight pawn taste King pace game over
everybody makes sense it makes sense to
me alright and that's all the mass all
right and obviously yeah if he plate is
not gonna play out 3f for cuz I'll just
take all right so so obviously
what movie is he gonna play instantly
obviously he's just gonna take right you
can't wait to take you know if I sit
there for 40 minutes as soon as I make
the movies gonna take all right even
though I could just say hey you're just
lost I calculate out every single
variation you're done
he's got to take it instantly anyway all
right so check all right so so now not
only do I have to analyze King to e3 I
have to analyze King the c3 all right
just for grins with which which way do
you want to analyze first this way or
this way whoever says something first
which way in three okay III all right so
what do we do be five no no we want to
win this pawn for free so first things
first we have to play this would be fun
to edit okay first we got a playoff if
we can if we can't h5 all right
so that prevents him from playing g4 is
that okay with everybody because if he
plays the move g4 we might be in a lot
of trouble all right so you could play
his pulling here and we'll just play our
pawn there if he plays pawn to a5 we'll
play pawn to a6 meaning guess what it's
his move and one what would he have to
play then all right so yeah
all right jobs now which I was playing
you in this position by 50 rating points
so I get you all right
uh-oh this is looking pretty bad for me
this is looking really bad for me oh but
he's he's so close can you believe it
can you believe it Jonathan check you
want to go toward the Queen check I'll
take you and then once he gets behind
the pawn there's no coming back
okay so that so that got to move
fifty-eight and I move 45 so I had to
calculate thirteen moves that way that
that was going to be a win all right
the whole thing about that the whole key
like in the other variation we'll see is
the move
h5 okay meaning that when he moves he's
going to eventually have to move away
from this pawn because if I didn't have
the move h5 in okay and he plays well he
would play a whatever so check so it's
my move so if I played like a five or
something okay and he got in the move g4
see how I would have to abandon my pawn
and he would take d5 you and your ePHI I
don't want to trade that pawn
opposition wait I mean the computer will
say equal probably all right that makes
sense
but the whole point is to get h5 and you
just win yeah and then it's gonna be the
same thing this way as well
okay so h5 do you want them to push the
pawn now or or not it's up to you you're
playing you're playing white yeah if you
think if you think you got a better
chance playing that it doesn't cuz when
I play a six now you can't get in there
you see all right so so that's pretty
much will play it out for everybody at
home so after h5 King here but you're
still gonna be too slow as white not by
much but all you have to be is just slow
by just one move
so tempo and the endgame very important
needless to say you're really slow
alright so if you have a pulling on the
third-ranked it doesn't take very long
for you to get the Queen going okay but
let's uh let's all see how the
11-hundred ended up playing that you
think he played in any of those
variations no so so this this this is
worth the price of a mission okay
alright so so we had those two
variations I guess he calculated out in
the 40 seconds he he made her play the
move yeah hey both those variations may
I'm just gonna be a little bit too slow
because of that that killer h5 okay so
so I guess he saw that so he plays King
at c3 I do play the move h5 obviously he
plays a5
all right so obviously I have to play
the move a six because I don't want to
abandon my space of the pawn all right
all right so now he plays up a doozy of
a move here f4 all right f4 so what do
you think we should do percent yes the
best moving all at chess all right boom
what happened I guess he didn't know
about that rule because because now I
got a passer and now he's in a lot of
trouble so I better go try to save them
King to d3 f2 King e2 King takes King
takes and now it's just a matter of time
won't won't bump the slow march you
can't take it anymore
okay game old oh all right so so
hopefully you got a lot out of that you
can play play defense by not even moving
your pieces right if if your piece is
already protected and you know they're
attacking it with the same amount of
pieces you can just ignore the threat
and let them take and then you take back
all right that's what Doug taught us all
right what did I teach you
when in doubt when you're mad just push
the Jeep on go for a King side attack
okay and in the end game you have to
actually calculate because one
miscalculation you'll lose all right
also in the endgame try not to trade
your pawns because that's the only way
you're ever gonna win by promoting upon
all right makes sense
all right hopefully you'll come back
next week for another installment of
beginner breakdown thank you all in the
live audience
you